It's great to be here.
Thanks very much for coming along.
Today I'm going to be talking about visualizing
enterprise data with D3.
It says enterprise in the title, but really,
it's about adding visualizations to any significant
dataset.
More than a hundred rows, a hundred records
in your datasets?
You may want to consider adding visualizations.
I'm using D3, awesome library.
The talk is broken up into two rough halves.
The first is demonstrating and why visualizations
are break, why to add them to applications
if you can.
Why they add value.
And the second half is how you can ramp up
with D3.
D3 is a powerful library.
It has a huge amount of power and potential.
Check out the gallery after the talk, it's
about every graph and visualization for any
use case.
The problem with D3 can be it has a fairly
steep learning curve.
So, the second half of the talk is just to
give you an introduction into the main entry
points how to get going with D3.
There's two rough halves.
So, increasingly as developers, depending
on which area and what we work on are facing
larger and larger datasets.
They're going to grow in financial, medical,
social media, the data we're getting is ever
increasing.
And that's hugely valuable.
We can do so much with this information.
Specifically, things like medical data.
What insights and breakthroughs are we going
to make with the huge amounts of data that
we are able to gather?
The problem is that large data is hard if
not impossible to understand.
If you're looking at a hundred rows of data,
for example, it can be hard to digest.
If you're looking at a million rows, well,
it's almost impossible.
Data is king.
It's absolutely king.
And we need to look at the underlying data
often.
So, most of my background is from a financial
background where it's not only important for
the user to confirm that the decision they're
about to make for a trade, for a loan, for
a mortgage, is based on actual accurate data.
So, they need to look at that data.
And there's often a regulatory requirement,
depending on your industry, to display that
data as well.
So, that's great and it's important.
That's not going to change.
But I think we can add a lot more value to
our users and allow them to get insights that
would be much harder otherwise with visualizations.
Humans are very visual animals.
We've evolved over, you know, thousands, hundreds
of years, thousands of years, to gain insights
quickly often rapidly.
And my favorite example of that are road signs.
We're able to gain, at a glance, often while
moving at speed, useful and critical information
in just one picture.
So, I think we can probably take that concept
and translate it and copy it over to whatever
application or sphere we're working in.
So, that's the aim of this talk, the first
half, anyway, to convince you and even courage
you to add visualizations.
And if you can and if it makes sense for your
domain and if you're not doing so already.
The data set we're going to look at as an
example is Olympic information.
It's Olympic datasets of all medals won of
all athletes from 2000 2012.
It's a simple dataset.
I didn't want to get something we would struggle
to understand before we could understand what
I was trying to illustrate.
This is fairly simple.
Per row, who won, how would they were, what
they won and what medals they won.
And see if we can derive any insights from
this dataset.
So, we'll switch over.
I'm using you can hopefully see that?
Yep.
So, we can already see it's already ordered
by total medals won.
We can see that Michael Phelps has won a significant
number of medals just in those three years.
That's fine.
We can see that Michael Phelps looks like
he's on top.
But let's assume, let's pretend there's other
athletes who have won not many in one year,
but many medals over many years.
It wouldn't necessarily be easy to get that
information.
You would think that Michael Phelps was at
the top.
Let's see if we can get some more information
from that.
So, let's group this by athlete.
So, now Michael Phelps, looks like he's on
top.
And aggregate by total medals won.
We can confirm that total medals won, Michael
Phelps is far and away with 22 medals.
We can expand that and go further.
That's useful, right?
But it's already required a few clicks and
drags.
We could get this set up front.
But still it can be difficult.
Let's group by country.
Let's see who has won the most medals.
And so, from this we can what's with my
so, the U.S., the United States is ahead by
some way.
Russia second, Germany, Australia, China and
then it tails off.
So, that's useful, right?
I guess we could have guessed that.
But it's clear already from this that the
United States is ahead.
But that doesn't tell us how they're ahead.
It doesn't tell us which sports they're ahead
in.
Did they win more bronzes than gold than anyone
else?
What's the proportion?
We can get that information from here.
We can always derive the insights we can gain
from visualizations from the raw data.
But it's much easier and much less resource
intensive, mentally resource intensive if
we can divide that information at a glance.
So, let's take a look at how to do that.
So, the visualizations, when I say that, what
do I mean?
Visualization is a process of translating
raw information into graphical visualization.
What I mean is that you are taking data and
making visualization format.
How it helps, in my opinion, for users
data.
And visualizations as [audio breaking up]
help user insights.
So, the application that I've put together
for this is going to have two halves.
On the left side it's going to have a component
with the raw data and confirm what we've seen.
And on the right side, some visualization
that goes along with the selected data and
what we're doing it to see if we can get a
better idea of what we're looking at.
The application's pretty simple.
I won't spend too much time on this.
But we have a good component.
That's responsible for managing the grid,
the configuration, what we do when we click
on resource.
We have a chart data service that will interact
with the chart service on the right.
And the grid component is also responsible
for switching out the chart component, depending
on what the user is asking it to do.
It's simple and the code will be available
after the talk.
But that's not the focus of the talk.
So, we'll go on to the actual application.
So, I've pre wrapped, pre wrapped three types
of visualizations we can do with this data.
So, we already think and know that the U.S.,
Russia, Australia, China are ahead in terms
of medals won.
Let's see if we can dig down into that.
Dig a little deeper.
So, let's group, select the top ten countries
by total medals won.
Not looking at the types of medals, gold,
silver and bronze.
But the total counts.
And take that.
Hopefully you can see that.
So, if you can't see the label at the bottom.
On the left, United States, Germany, Australia,
China, Russia, trailing off.
That confirm what is we have seen earlier.
But what I like about this starting point
is visually we don't have to use too much
energy to work out that the United States
is by far and away the winner here in terms
of total medals won.
Almost just under double Russia.
Looks like maybe just double Germany and Australia.
So, it's the same information we got before.
But we're able to divide that information
within maybe two seconds, maybe three, maybe
more.
But ultimately, we will be able to derive
a huge amount of information, which we were
able to derive before, but a lot less scanning
horizontally and vertically.
We can glance at the picture, look at the
label, and United States is by far, in terms
of total medals won the number one winner.
Let's see if we can derive more information
from the dataset we're looking at.
So, we're doing the same thing, but now we're
breaking it down by the medal types.
And I think this is my favorite one is that
it puts a distance between the United States
and the rest that isn't necessarily obvious
from the raw data and grouping aggregation
or even the first visualization.
So, looking at this, you can see that the
bronze is about on par with Russia.
Silvers are about double Russia and the other
countries.
But gold is almost triple everyone else.
So, not only with the United States ahead
in overall, they are ahead by some way in
gold.
And silver.
And about on par with bronze.
That's a huge amount of information that we
were able to derive in almost no time and
with almost no effort.
As developers, we had to put a bit of effort
to do this.
But your user, by clicking on a button and
selecting the information they're after is
able to derive a huge amount of information
just by having the visualization to go alongside
the data.
Now, imagine translating this to aricher
dataset.
Maybe looking at social media, and trends.
Complicated trends.
Not easy trends.
Medical, where hot spots are for diseases
and why they are occurring.
Visualizations would help.
The last visualization, the colors are terrible.
Top ten for athletics.
The United States is first, but in terms of
Jamaica and Ethiopia are in the top ten by
a significant margin.
And given their population count relative
to the United States and Russia, we can see
they are punching far above their weight in
terms of population.
While not as impactful as the second, it's
telling us that U.S. and Russia are ahead,
but in terms of population, much smaller countries
are doing really well in athletics.
That's just with one little chart.
That's great and hopefully illustrates the
point I'm trying to make.
So, that's the first half.
I encourage you to check out D3, the visualizations,
what the options are.
The second part of the talk is just to dig
into D3 a little bit.
When I started D3, a little bit overwhelmed.
The documentation is there but it's definitely
not geared towards beginners.
The rest of the talk is the basics of D3 and
how you can get started with it and the concepts.
So, we'll start off with selection.
Like JQuery, it allows for selection of DOM
elements.
At the top, I'll set up the startup point,
I'm demo in a minute.
We have the number of circles within and the
D3 code is at the bottom.
We have some data.
We have five data items there.
And we're going to use D3 to select all circles
and associate data with it.
Okay?
So, if we go look at that, we'll see that
D3 is actually doing something with us.
That's how the code looks as it is.
And we've run the code and D3, hopefully you
can read that.
I'll pull it up for those at the back.
The HTML is rendered, D3 hasn't changed what
we are seeing.
But it has done something in the background.
Let's look at the first item.
The first circle on the left.
If we selected.
I have given an ID, so we selected.
and we can go right down to the bottom.
Hopefully you can see that, maybe you have
not.
Added data__ and given it a value of 2.
And the second one, 4 and 6.
And it's found all existing DOM items and
asked to select and associated the data we've
asked it to associate with it.
We can expand on that just to confirm what
I'm saying.
So, we've iterated all the circles and I'll
put the data item and you can hopefully see
it says 2, 4, 6, 8.
Each of the circles has the data we have given
it associated with it.
And that's important because subsequent steps
to manipulate the DOM items will use the data
associated with it.
You may have noticed that we have five data
items, but only four circles.
We'll come back to that in a minute.
So, let's put that away.
So, the second step here is to beg your
pardon.
There.
So, we've selected it.
The second step will be to start manipulating
the existing items.
So, I'll show you the code in a minute.
That was quite quick.
It's on the slide.
We'll use the items we associated with the
DOM items and scaled it.
So, for example, 2, we've times it by a value.
4, we've timed it by a value and the circles
have scaled in size.
So, this is, I guess, D3101, select DOM
items.
Manipulate the DOM items with the data.
So, let's look at what we did there.
So, the second step we've selected we did
before.
We've selected the circles.
We associated data with it.
And then we've changed the style of the DOM
items.
So, for each item, so, D3, like JQuery, allows
chaining of items.
And D3 starts at the top left and draws down
and to the right.
So, we will change the height according to
the data item and the width according to the
data item, so the circles get bigger.
Depending on the size of the data.
And at the bottom, we've manipulated the margin
so that as humans we expect the graph and
visualizations to go from bottom up.
We just push the margin top down and allow
for the data.
If we started at the bottom and scrolled up,
we wouldn't have to do that.
But like D3, like most graphing libraries,
start at the top and go down.
We manipulate the library.
I have broken them out into four points to
illustrate what each item is doing.
For each data item, we are manipulating one
attribute of the style.
So, moving on so, that's selection and
manipulating items.
That's great for when you want to manipulate
existing DOM items.
As I said before, we have five data items,
but only four existing images.
This brings us to the second concept, or D3
concept that I wanted to introduce.
That's the enter selection.
On the left, existing items, that's selection.
On the right we then add new items using the
enter method.
So, you'll see I have four existing items.
The fifth one, 10, will be added by as you
add enter and then manipulating the DOM item.
So, the top half of this code is the code
we've already seen.
And the bottom half, we could change this,
I have broken it up into separate items to
make it clear.
We use enter.
Everything that's not already associated,
do this with it.
So, for every item we're not associated we
add a div and we put the attributes as we
did before.
So, this is going to add a fifth circle with
a height with this was how before and add
it to our application.
So, let's take a look at that.
As I said, you can chain these.
And you can make it in line, but for demonstration
purposes I wanted to make it clearer.
So, four items with the fifth circle added.
So, selection for existing DOM items.
Enter for new DOM items.
It's pretty simple.
It's just not always clear from the D3 documentation
and demos what these things are actually doing.
The last three items I want to touch on are
scales.
And these are how you want to scale your data
both horizontally and vertically depending
on your data.
So, for example, if you've got 2, 4, 6, 8,
10, but you actually want to fill up your
screen with a thousand pixels horizontally
and 800 pixels, add scales.
If you want to use dates, that's where scales
come in.
I'm going to there's many types of scales,
but the three main you're likely to use I'll
cover.
The first is an ordinal scale.
It maps discrete values in an array to discrete
values in the array.
We wanted to map to RGB, we use it here.
Set the domain, the data, and I want the output
to be red, G for green, B for blue.
And when you call ordinal scale, when we manipulate
the items, it will return.
Ordinal scale of R returns red.
A discrete value to a discrete value, it's
pretty simple, I think.
The second one is band scales.
Which is similar to ordinal, but it's a continuous
range.
Instead of a discrete value to a discrete
value, we're going from a discrete value to
an item on a range.
So, as before, we've got RGB as our data.
But that's going to scale between 0 and 200.
So, R is zero, G is 6, about halfway, I guess,
and B is 133.
And loop over.
So, if we do it again, it will go to zero.
So, that's more useful when you want a continuous
scale.
And lastly, the linear scale.
This is the one you'll probably use most often.
You'll use it when you want a continuous domain,
numbers, dates, for example.
And typically, this will be your Y axis.
So, you've got a set amount of data items,
but you want to scale it horizontally.
You'll use a linear scale for that.
Here we create a linear scale.
We set out the main, zero and 10.
That's our data items.
So, the start and the max of our data items.
The range will go from zero to a thousand.
And we want to scale that continuously on
our range.
So, a zero is a zero.
2.5, as you'd expect, given the numbers, would
be 250.
7 would be 700 and obviously 10 would be a
thousand.
So, it's for mapping items items that are
smaller or bigger than you want to render
on your screen and scaling them on to a screen.
I hope that makes sense.
Those are the three main scales.
I would like to have gone into this a bit
further, but time constraints.
Hopefully that gives you an instruction into
D3.
Hopefully that introduces you to the three
scales you'll likely use.
And encourage you to check out D3.
It's got a huge amount of visualizations.
More than I can describe here.
And all that you're likely to encounter.
All use those I've described.
If you're not using visualizations, consider
adding them.
Your users will thank you.
They can get so much more information than
they would otherwise just from the raw data.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]